de l'actualité de ce mercredi 3 mars un
horizon et des restrictions l'exécutif
prévoit des semaines de gros temps mais
espère un retour à une vie plus normale
peut-être dès la mi-avril conférence de
presse de jean castex
quoi qu'il en soit ce jeudi à 18 heures
avec à la clé peut-être l' annonce de
nouvelles mesures de restriction pour
une vingtaine de départements sous
surveillance renforcée
[Musique]
outre atlantique même son cloche qu'en
france ce n'est pas le moment de lever
toutes les restrictions selon les
autorités sanitaires
joe biden promet des vaccins pour tous
les adultes d'ici à la fin mai le
président américain compte sur l'arrivée
du vaccin johnson and johnson pour
accélérer la campagne de vaccination le
texas lui lève l'obligation du port du
masque et rouvre totalement son économie
moscou dénonce les nouvelles sanctions
prises à son encontre dans le cas de la
sphère navalni après l'union européenne
les etats-unis ont annoncé hier une
série de mesures visant des hauts
responsables russes
pour le kremlin ces nouvelles sanctions
sont absolument inacceptables et nuisent
considérablement aux relations déjà
déplorable entre la russie et les
occidentaux
[Musique]
il
c'est donc devenu un rituel conseil de
défense ce matin suivi du fameux conseil
des ministres une conférence de presse
de jean castex demain à 18 heures pour
plus de précisions sur la situation
sanitaire et d'éventuels perspective
nous retrouvons tout de suite monahan ou
dès lors en direct de l'elysée bonsoir
mona que faut-il retenir de ce conseil
de défense sanitaire en clair qu est ce
qui nous attend demain et bien gabriela
talent le porte-parole du gouvernement à
l'issue de ce conseil de défense
sanitaire a pris est la parole alors pas
d'annoncé sur les potentiels
restrictions à venir rien de nouveau n'a
été annoncé en revanche un retour
presque à la normale serait envisagé et
d'ici quelques semaines tenez bon ce
sont les mots du porte-parole du
gouvernement il y aurait peut-être
finalement de la lumière au bout du
tunnel c'est en tout cas ce qu'a laissé
entendre et gabriela tel jeu vous
propose eu deux l'écouté vacciner les
plus fragiles
je le redis c'est protéger notre hôpital
et protéger notre hôpital c'est nous
donner une chance de pouvoir desserrer
le plus rapidement possible les
contraintes qui pèsent sur nos vies
quotidiennes et qui pèsent sur le pays
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois ne
s'agit pas d'un horizon lointain et
incertain
il s'agit d'un horizon de plus en plus
proche peut-être nous l'espérons dès la
mi avril auquel nous nous préparons et
le président nous a demandé de présenter
des dispositifs et des protocoles qui
pourrait permettre de rouvrir prudemment
mais sûrement le pays dans les prochains
temps une réunion se tiendra à vous le
savez autour du président de la
république
cet après midi en ce sens selon
porte-parole du gouvernement les
premiers effets de la vaccination se
font ressentir à noter qu'un nouveau
vaccin va faire son entrée en europe
d'ici quelques semaines l'américain
johnson & johnson il serait est efficace
à 66% une seule dose sera nécessaire et
il serait moins cher que les autres
vaccins et mona cet après midi donc
comme le disait gabriela talent s'est
tenue à l'elysée
réunion le président était entouré de
plusieurs ministres quels thèmes ont été
abordés alors c'était une réunion pour
appuyer et puis mettre en place les
prochains dispositif qui concernerait
est les vingt départements placés sous
surveillance et qui permettrait
peut-être la réouverture de certains
lieux fermés
le président avait également abordé les
modalités d'un pass sanitaire concernant
lé musées les cinémas les salles de
sport s'il était amené à rouvrir alors
même si le président de la république
veut insuffler de l'espoir aux français
le porte parole du gouvernement l'a dit
la situation reste tout de même
préoccupante et mona sait rien n'a été
divulgué aujourd'hui donc il faudra
attendre demain
exactement il faudra attendre la
traditionnelle conférence de presse qui
sera donnée par jean castex et olivier
véran qui donneront un peu plus
d'informations sur les nouvelles mesures
les nouvelles restrictions concernant
ces vingt départements placés sous
surveillance mais attention comme l'a
précisé
avec gabriel attal le président de la
république ne veut pas se précipiter il
va faire du cas par cas pas car il sait
que chaque décision sera lourde de
conséquences sur le moral à des français
il faudra donc prendre son mal en
patience et attendre demain pour en
savoir plus mais le gouvernement s'est
peut-être précipité a donné la date d'un
retour à une vie presque normal
puisqu'on l'a vu l'épidémie nous a
réservé bien des surprises tivement
monaco dès lors en direct de l'elysée
merci à vous alors les français en tout
cas sont opposés au confinement
résultats d'un sondage de l'institut est
là pour 1 bfmtv six français sur dix ne
veulent pas d'un couvre feu de 18h et
d'un confinement le week-end sur le plan
national 58% sont opposés un conte
finances muller au deuxième quand ils
l'ont de novembre ils sont autant à
refuser l'idée d'un confinement
similaires au mois de mars 2020 seule
mesure approuvée par une petite majorité
des sondés 54%
l'idée d'un couvre feu la semaine et
d'un confinement le week-end mais
attention seulement pour les régions les
plus touchées et donc l'interdiction
également de se déplacer d'une région à
l'autre
une chose est certaine approche de la
date anniversaire le 16 mars au début du
premier confirmant la lassitude
l'emportent chez les français en cause
aucune perspective des logements ni de
calendrier précis qui permettrait
d'entrevoir une sortie de crise alors
vous ton avec les nerfs des français
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
dre pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric jeanjean secrétaire général
humides des bouches du rhône vous êtes
donc un patron de la brasserie des
templiers da cité phocéenne bruno
megaman médecin vous êtes le chef du
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière dans le 10e arrondissement
à paris l ex époux là qu'on connaît bien
ici éditorialistes bonsoir à tous les
trois merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on vient d'entendre un
le pas parole du gouvernement qui essaye
un petit peu au détour de quelques
phrases de nous remonter le moral de
nous donner une forme de calendrier il
n'empêche il nous dit quand même dans le
même temps c'est à la main de cette
expression qui lie à une hausse
considérable des cas alors je vais me
tourner vers vous docteur tout d'abord
vous en parlerez mieux que personne
quelle est la situation à l'hôpital
notamment dans votre hôpital
lariboisière à paris l'un des plus
grands hôpitaux parisiens d'écouter la
situation à l'hôpital en ile de france
comme dans beaucoup de régions
françaises et celles des hôpitaux tendu
effectivement la totalité des lits de
réanimation sont occupées un pourcentage
très important de ces lits sont occupés
par des patients qui ont une forme grave
de kobe de 19
donc en fait nos marges de manoeuvre
style y avait brutalement une arrivée
importante de patients l'hôpital est
extrêmement limitée c'est pourquoi
évidemment gouvernement et les autorités
sanitaires propose éventuellement un
renforcement des mesures de restrictions
afin de protéger le système hospitalier
qui pourrait en cas de difficulté ne pas
pouvoir proposer une prise en charge
optimale aux patientes qui viendrait
pour les copies de 19 alors frédéric
jeanjean je me tourne vers vous
j'imagine ça vous fait bondir par scop
bien évidemment vous vous mettez à la
place de ce docteur et des malades et ça
doit être évidemment voilà implacable
comme argument on ne peut pas
pour gestione les services d'urgence le
docteur qui propose de renforcer ces
restrictions mais de vous de votre côté
on imagine que vous êtes à bout bien
évidemment quand on vous parle de
confinement ça doit vous dresser le poil
s'écouter et rappeler maintenant un an
quinze jours ça fera un an que nous
sommes dans cette situation
qu'est ce qui a été fait pour aider
l'hôpital depuis un an
ça c'était la question que je voudrais
poser gouvernement parce que il s'agit
pas de dire il va falloir où il va
falloir mettre des mesures qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour accompagner ont fait des
effets d'annoncé pour aider nos
entreprises à l'heure actuelle le
gouvernement avait lancé tout un tas de
mesures
au jour d'aujourd'hui une convention à
peine à percevoir les aides du mois de
janvier
ça fait deux mois deux mois de décalage
je vous rappelle qu'au terme du kadiogo
nous avons 45 jours il ya quinze jours
ne loue pas vous acquitter de nos
factures parce que nous n'avons les
crédits à payer
nous avons des loyers à payer une
baguette était une manière stricte
vis-à-vis de ses débiteurs et bien nous
à ce moment nous devons nous mettre sous
la protection du tribunal de commerce
alors que l'hôpital soit en tension on a
entendu ces plaignants ça fait un art
rappelez vous il ya une heure on avait
l'espagne qui se retrouvaient la main se
mettre des sacs poubelle je te tue au
cul parce qu'on avait plus de blues
parce qu'on n'avait pas de masque
alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
fait des annonces mais concrètement on
n'y est pas alors oui on sait qu'il ya
des problèmes
les demies cette problématique de
l'épidémie oui j'en sais que le
l'hôpital
attention mais derrière il n'ya une
désespérante est temps de se lever à
travers tout le pays en ce que ces
mesures dures et que concrètement on n'a
pas répondu à la problématique de
l'hôpital alexis poullan c'est bien de
ça qu'il s'agit
on lisait les nerfs des français à vif
c'est vrai qu'on entend le docteur nous
dire voilà les urgences ont sont saturés
l'autre côté les français s'interrogent
tous les jours on attend fébrilement la
petite conférence de presse de jean
castex pour savoir à quelle sauce on va
être mangé on entend la mairie de paris
demandé un confinement emmanuel macron
qui ne le souhaite pas vraiment en ile
de france ce que c'est pas là le
problème de ne pas avoir
on le dit souvent d'objectifs précis de
calendrier précis
alors ni calendrier ni même une volonté
de gérer cette crise de manière
sanitaire je le dit et répété on a géré
cette crise de manière sécuritaire
autoritaire n'est pas sanitaires on a
ces conseils de défense un jeu présidée
par emmanuel macron sous le secret
défense donc on ne sait pas ce qu'il
s'est dit ni quelles sont les décisions
on a une une opacité à la fois sur les
chiffres puisque kobe tracker demandent
à avoir accès à des documents
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas par exemple
quels sont les la proportion des
variants sur le territoire national les
chiffres aussi drs qui avait été remis
en cause dans le sud on est dans
l'improvisation permanente de ces
amateurs fiers qu'ils continuent d'être
fiers d'en fermer les français à 18h et
de les enfermer maintenant le week-end
et puis au delà de cette épidémie grave
réel avec le co vide
on va avoir après cela une épidémie de
cancers qui n'ont pas été traités à
temps on a déjà une épidémie de suicides
de dépressions un grand malaise
psychologique au sein de la population
parce que ça fait un an qu'on ne sait
pas et aujourd'hui au lieu d'avoir un
cap clair au lieu d'avoir une
vaccination qui fonctionne qui démarre
au quart de tour
eh bien on a encore une fois une
campagne de vaccination qui fait pschitt
comme l'avaient fait les masques à
l'époque comme l'avaient fait les tests
à l'époque
tout ça est bien s'accumulent et
commence à faire beaucoup à la fois pour
les français qui travaillent les
français qui ont peur qui sont sujets à
des comorbidités et qui aimeraient
pouvoir être vacciné tout ça va très mal
et on continue avec évidemment ses
conférences de presse de jean castex une
semaine sur deux il ne dit rien et
l'autre semaine il nous enferme ça
commence à bien faire
alors en tout cas dans la communauté
scientifique certains demandent au
gouvernement de taper fort c'est le cas
par exemple du chef du service des
maladies infectieuses de l'hôpital tenon
gilles pialoux on écoute je ne vois pas
comment on peut
meaney et la pression dans les hôpitaux
sans passer par une mesure de
confinement il faut diminuer la
circulation du virus et ça ne passera
que par des mesures drastiques
il faut aussi donner les conditions de
sortie de cette pression il faut des
règles strictes de déconfinement bruno
emmenegger ban clairement il faut des
règles strictes des mesures drastiques
parce que c'est vrai que cette affaire
de couvre-feu à 18 heures qui perdure
emmanuel là qu'on le souhaite encore
pour quatre à six semaines si j'ai bien
compris avec un confinement le week end
est ce que c'est vraiment utile ou ça me
fait justement que m les nerfs à vif un
de nos compatriotes
alors vous avez bien compris en fait le
gouvernement a choisi une stratégie de
compromis c'est-à-dire mettre en place
un certain nombre de mesures de
restriction mais quand même limiter les
conséquences sociales économiques
psychologiques de telles mesures sur la
population mais fait effectivement un
compliment
un confinement strict aurait des
conséquences beaucoup bien meilleurs
signaux la baisse de la circulation du
virus
malgré tout évidemment il faudrait
fermer les écoles fermer les commerces
donné l'ordre de ne pas sortir de chez
soi et donc c'est extrêmement
problématique l'acceptabilité n'est pas
ne seraient pas bonnes donc il vaut
mieux je pense des mesures ciblées
graduée à la situation épidémique de
chaque région plutôt qu'un confinement
national très strictes qui de toute
façon il devrait être maintenu au moins
quatre semaines pour aboutir à une
diminution significative de l'épidémie
pour permettre aux stratégies de
dépister tracé isolé de fonctionner il
faut pas imaginer qu'une petite semaine
de confinement strict permettrait de
régler le problème et qu'ensuite on
pourrait retrouver la vie d'avant c'est
totalement impossible car aussitôt le
des confinement total instauré
l'épidémie au progrès seraient encore
plus un niveau encore plus élevé que ce
à partir duquel le confinement a été
instauré il faut au minimum quatre
semaines pour pouvoir instaurer un
contrôle épidémiologique par le
dépistage est probablement pour ceux qui
sont amateurs du coe j
zéro au moins quatre mois de confinement
pour pouvoir le réaliser on voit bien qu
évidemment tout ça aura des conséquences
tout le choix du gouvernement de mesures
certes de restrictions mais néanmoins
compatible avec une certaine qualité de
vie
oui effectivement on le sait maintenant
qu emmanuel macron ne n'est pas
franchement pour le confinement pour lui
c'est vraiment du tout dernier recours
frédéric jeanjean d'ailleurs il ya eu
une réunion à mon âme ou dès lors il
disait tout à l'heure à l'elysée avec
notamment les les restaurateurs ce que
vous seriez prêt à accepter pour ouvrir
et les limites
vous avez eu des échos ça va quand même
dans le bon sens pour vous vous sentez à
la fin du tunnel
écoutez en tout cas on allait annoncer
qu'ils vont dans le sens quand il
réellement de savoir ce que l'on peut
dire c'est que nous avons proposé à
travers lui mika
l'hôtellerie-restauration l'ouverture
des terrasses et je peux faire remarquer
auprès de réunions d'azur que sur le
depor l opéra de marseille
tous les midis on avait cru utile
dimanche plastique par terre ils mangent
sur les bains ils sont regroupés on
dirait des bandes de moins la période de
la reproduction
ils s'en foutent et du coup le virus
circule si vous mourez les terrains
l'espace n'est pas à y régner en plein
air
lemoine était nourri les terrasses nos
propres les sanitaires le cahier de rap
il permet de savoir qui est parce qu on
envoie ça permet effectivement de mieux
contrôler ce qui se passe et comment ce
n'est plus le virus à ce que j'ai
commandé au fait vous pouvez vous me
dire à qui a mangé sur le quai au port
ou devant l'opéra les gars courent dans
cette lutte il est donc on avait posé sa
il ya près de trois mois
nous n'avons toujours pas de réponse
alors faire des annonces nuit c'est
facile on peut les voir
moi je veux faire des annonces même vous
dire que j'ai raser gratis que c'était
mais ceci dit quand on se rend compte
qu'on a un gouvernement qui n'entend pas
autour de lui une une
j que technocrates inc avec on le voit
un hôpital où les problématiques n'ont
pas été réglés et je tiens vraiment à
remercier ainsi milliers tout le travail
qui paie pour les soignants ne s'agit
pas de dire aux compositions qu'on
comprend pas ce qui se passe mais quand
même un problème de gouvernance gestion
de cet opus qui se pose alors un autre
en colère je voudrais vous faire écouter
le député elle est fille du nord en rien
quoi tenance justement sur ce thème on
ne peut pas continuer comme nous sommes
embarqués là on ne peut pas continuer
entre déconfinement d'aidé confinement
déconfinement locaux des couvre-feux il
faut renforcer les protocoles sanitaires
et organiser la société de telle manière
que la vie la vraie puissent reprendre
c'est à dire organiser déroulement dans
tous les secteurs de la société
nous sommes pas que des êtres économique
qui se lève le matin pour aller
travailler
rentrer se reposer et reconstituer leur
force de travail on a besoin de se
rencontrer
alexis poulain c'est vrai que cette
liberté confiné on sent que la pilule
commence à être difficile à avaler
j'ai pas l'habitude de parler de mes
propres expériences mais enfin hier je
suis parti voilà du travail à 22h30 j'ai
mis une heure et demie à rentrer chez
moi parce qu'ils ont bloqué le
périphérique
ils ont installé des contrôles de police
et y avait pas d des routiers qui venait
sans doute de faire huit heures voilà
deux camions pour aller livrer des
choses certainement des travailleurs est
ce que c'est vrai que ce genre de mesure
est ce que c'est bien la solution on
rompt demandant l'avis du médecin mais
c'est vrai que ça commence simple qui
peut être un petit peu lourd pour les
français tout ça mais c'est voyant c'est
à dire qu'en france on répond à une
crise sanitaire avec des moyens de
police des moyens répressifs des amendes
à 135 euros à 18 heures on est très
fiers de voir qu'il ya des renforts
policiers pour empêcher les gens d'aller
sur la plage à dunkerque ou pour
empêcher les gens d'accéder au littoral
à nice on marche sur la tête ce sont des
mesures qui sont là des mesures de
répression des mesures de contrôle des
populations mais certainement pas des
mesures sanitaires c'est vraiment la
politique du pauvre parce qu'on a cassé
l'hôpital pendant des années parce que
on applaudit les soignants il ya un an
et on continue de les applaudir parce
qu'ils sont en première ligne et qu'ils
font un travail formidable mais n'ont
pas
les moyens de faire leur travail ils
font ce qu'ils peuvent avec des bouts de
chandelles ils ont été laissés seuls à
gérer cette crise et le reste eh bien
c'est quoi c'est le bâton la mangue 135
euros et rendre la vie impossible aux
français alors oui une société de
roulement pourquoi pas mais pour ça il
faut que les vaccins arrivent qu'ils
soient efficaces que les gens puissent
ressortir et puis autorisé aussi les
gens à ne plus avoir peur à dire pour
écouter oui la l'épidémie est là faites
attention respectez les gestes barrière
mais maintenant il va falloir quand même
recommencé les gens commencent à penser
printemps les jours se rallongent les
températures augmentent d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui fait que le virus va commencer à
- circulent également
donc là aujourd'hui on est en train
d'accepter un plateau à 300 morts par
jour en disant c'est pas si mal
finalement on va continuer comme ça on
n'aura pas de zéro co vite parce que
c'est devenu impossible on ne va pas
évidemment fermé les gens quatre mois ça
c'est quelque chose d'impossible mais en
revanche on peut commencer effectivement
à rouvrir pourquoi pas des terrasses des
lieux de culture il a été prouvé que ce
n'est pas dans des salles de théâtre et
de cinéma qu'on on attrape locaux vides
et puis et puis voir comment tout ça
peut petit à petit remettre les gens à
retrouver du bonheur à la fois d'être
ensemble et puis de revivre une vie
humaine de culture de rencontre parce
que évidemment métro boulot dodo
qu'ovide ça commence à bien faire
1 bruno mais garvan quand vous nous
écoutez là vous vous dites voilà c'est
une bande d'égoïstes inconscients ils ne
se rendent pas compte ou où vous
comprenez que cette acceptation devient
compliqué voilà pour pour la population
il ya quelque chose qui tourne pas rond
dans cette manière d'aborder cette
stratégie sanitaire
donc évidemment que je comprends tout ça
bien sûr à nouveau je ne suis pas du
tout un défenseur du confinement
comme mesure de prévention ou de
contrôle de l'épidémie à nouveau ce sont
les mesures barrières le port du masque
notamment dans les lieux clos la
pédagogie la responsabilisation qui sont
les éléments les plus importants même si
on imposait des mesures de restriction
si la population ne comprenait pas ce
qu'il faudrait faire
eh bien on a vous tirez pas aux
résultats attendus en fait il faut
savoir que le confinement notamment pour
que l'on discute actuellement dans la
situation actuelle n'est que parce
qu'effectivement l'hôpital manque de
moyens nous n'avons pas de nous aurions
10 à 15% de lits supplémentaires
notamment en réanimation
nous ne serions pas là en train de
discuter avec malheureusement aucun line
a été créée depuis un an nous sommes
avec nos fameux 5000 lits et tout
compris c'est à dire les lits de
réanimation pédiatrique de géorgie de
chirurgie cardiaque donc réellement de
façon insuffisante
nous travaillons en permanence à plus
tendus les marges de manoeuvre en cas
d'augmentation de la demande sont quasi
nulles et de fait il faut des programmes
et fermer d'autres services redéployer
le personnel pour pouvoir prendre en
charge les patients la difficulté est là
évidemment le confinement et les mesures
de restriction ne sont là aujourd'hui
que pour sauver ses erreurs stratégiques
commises depuis une dizaine d'années sur
l'hôpital public qui a fini par être
étouffée je rappelle que la situation
actuelle n'a rien à voir avec mars avril
évidemment en mars avril le confinement
était indispensable car une maladie
nouvelle
sabathé sur le pays sans que l'on
connaisse ni les moyens de contamination
ni le cadre médical dans lequel ça
pouvait arriver
ni évidemment les facteurs de risque
aujourd'hui la situation est totalement
différente
on peut parfaitement mesurer la
progression de la maladie simplement
évidemment nous n'avons pas les moyens
de faire face à l'augmentation du nombre
de patients c'est bien
prix merci en tout cas bruno m'égare ban
merci à frédéric jeanjean en espérant
peut-être des annonces favorables
puisque ya eu des réunions et autour du
président de la république concernant
les restaurateurs et merci également à
alexis poulain d'avoir été avec nous et
à l'échelle européenne à présent alors
que certains états membres de l'union
européenne s'agace de la lenteur du
déploiement des vaccins d'autres passent
à l'action la slovaquie décide de se
fournir auprès de la russie et ce sans
attendre la validation par l' agence
européenne du vaccin spoutnik v
l'autriche
quant à elle se penche sur la création
vaccin deuxième génération grégoire
douce et face à l'urgence la patience a
ses limites l'immense défi qui
représente la vaccination d'un continent
entier fait craindre à certains membres
de l'union européenne que le processus
s'éternise pour la slovaquie ce doute
poussent les autorités à se fournir hors
du cadre de l'ua et le choix s'est porté
sur le vaccin russe spoutnik vais dans
ce pays où le taux de mortalité face au
coc u19 est l'un des plus élevés au
monde
[Musique]
vous pouvez voir derrière moi le premier
envoi des deux millions de vaccins
spoutnik vie que nous avons demandé à la
russie
j'ai je pense qu'en respectant les
délais les approvisionnements promis la
russie prouvera qu'elle est un
partenaire stable sur lequel tous vous
comptez en ces temps difficiles
victor l'autriche de son côté anticipent
l'avenir en se penchant sur un
partenariat avec israël et le danemark
pour se doter de vaccins deuxième
génération indépendamment de l'union
européenne l'agencé européenne des
médicaments est trop lente approuvé les
vaccins et il y à des goulets
d'étranglement dans l'approvisionnement
de la part des sociétés pharmaceutiques
nous devons donc nous préparer à
d'autres mutations et ne plus dépendre
uniquement de l'union européenne pour la
production de vaccins de 2
ème génération bruxelles qui pour sa
part appelle à la patience et se défend
face aux nombreuses critiques concernant
la politique vaccinale des 27
le fait est que nous sommes en plein
déploiement des vaccins et des
stratégies de vaccination dans toute
l'union européenne ue qui je vous le
rappelle compte 450 millions d'habitants
et non quelque chose comme 10 millions
comme israël
vous savez donc il faut garder le sens
des proportions concerne le défi que
nous devons relever par rapport à un
pays en particulier
peut-être oui faith ce n'est donc pas
comme si vous pouviez prendre un modèle
est simplement le maître vous savez le
coller sur l'union européenne et dire
que c'est ce que vous devriez faire à
l'heure actuelle seuls près de 5% de la
population autrichienne est à peine nuit
pour cent des danois ont reçu une
première dose du c'est romantique au
vide
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
un nom partiront aux états unis joe
biden promet des vaccins pour tous tous
les adultes en tout cas d'ici à la fin
mai le président américain compte sur
l'arrivée du vaccin johnson and johnson
pour accélérer la campagne et puis nous
reviendrons sur les nouvelles sanctions
prises à l'encontre de la russie dans le
cadre de l' affaire n'avait ni pour le
kremlin sont absolument inacceptables et
nuisent considérablement aux relations
déjà déplorable entre la russie et les
occidentaux
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
jordan barre de la et marion maréchal-le
pen qui dénonce cette censure pour eux
facebook menaçant fait de publier des
pages de soutien mouvement génération
identitaire il faut en finir avec cette
dérive dégâts femmes il faut rappeler la
primauté du droit français sur le
territoire national les pouvoirs publics
en france et dans d'autres pays sont un
peu tétanisé face aux géants du
numérique
moi j'ai eu l'occasion il ya quelques il
ya deux ans au parlement européen d'
interpeller
mark zuckerberg le pdg de facebook sur
cette question il y avait d'ailleurs
répondu de manière très alambiquée mais
je crois que ça nécessite maintenant que
les pouvoirs publics se saisissent du
sujet ils défendent la liberté
d'expression et s'ils ne le font pas et
bien compris
et
et il n'y a pas une façon plus une
pauvre de défendre un système que de
dire qu'il est moins pire que nous
trouve le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'ya
pas intervenir on sort du public
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers uniforme c'est quand même
des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï et gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui le droit il doit éviter les
dérives idéologiques merci de le
souligner comment peut-on reconstituer
une sixième république qui ne soient pas
publics parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est on dirait qu il y
a quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
tiacoh politique n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui est
extrêmement tous les témoins de notre
époque sont dans la grande interview
[Musique]
20h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france direction les états unis ce
n'est pas le moment de lever toutes les
restrictions alerte les autorités
sanitaires joe biden comme est lui un
vaccin à tous les américains et six
femmes et un pari ambitieux locataire de
la maison blanche compte sur
l'accélération de la production de doses
de sérum anti qu'ovide au texas en
revanche l'étau se resserre le port du
masque n'est plus obligatoire et tous
les commerces ont repris leur activité
sérielle bruit au texas
fini le port du masque cet état du sud
des états unis pourtant lourdement
touchés par le virus
avec plus de quarante quatre mille morts
lève des restrictions en place depuis
près de huit mois
le gouverneur greg abbott a annoncé ce
mardi la réouverture totale des
commerces d'ici la semaine prochaine une
décision à contre courant pour ce
territoire qui compte 29 millions
d'habitants à près de six mois la
plupart des entreprises sont ouvertes à
75 ou 50% et pendant cette période trop
de texans ont été écartés des
possibilités d'emploi trop de
propriétaires de petites entreprises ont
eu du mal à payer leurs factures
il faut que cela cesse il est maintenant
temps d'ouvrir le texas à 100%
une initiative pourtant loin d'être
isolé aux états unis d'autres états ont
également annoncé la levée des
restrictions tels que le michigan la
louisiane ou encore le mississippi à
chicago les élèves ont retrouvé le
chemin de l'école cette semaine tandis
que les restaurants du massachussets ont
reçu l'autorisation de rouvrir sans
limite de capacité un regain de
confiance outre atlantique liées à la
campagne de vaccination qui bat son
plein dans le pays
ce mardi le président américain joe
biden a tenu un discours optimiste
concernant sa stratégie vaccinale
et je tiens à remercier johnson and
johnson et merck d'avoir pris les
devants et d'avoir été de bons citoyens
corporatifs pendant cette crise
nationale
voici ce que tout cela signifie nous
sommes maintenant en bonne voie pour
avoir suffisamment de vaccins pour
chaque adulte en amérique 10 il a formé
un nouveau cap qui se précise pour les
américains alors que joe biden avait
évoqué il ya quelques semaines
l'objectif de vacciner tous les adultes
d'ici fin juillet une accélération de la
campagne que le président explique par
une collaboration historique à propos du
vaccin d'une firme américaine today et
aujourd'hui nous annonçons un grand pas
en avant
deux des plus grandes entreprises de
soins de santé et pharmaceutique du
monde qui sont généralement concurrentes
travaillent ensemble sur le vaccin
johnson and johnson et merck vont
travailler ensemble pour augmenter la
production du vaccin dès johnson and
johnson
c'est le type de collaboration entre
entreprises que nous avons vue pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale deux
avantages conséquents face au vaccin de
johnson johnson
ce dernier ne nécessite qu'une seule
dose est peut-être plus facilement
stockées à des températures de
réfrigérateur pour le moment
le groupe pharmaceutique a certifié
l'envoi de 100 millions de doses aux
états unis avant la fin du mois de juin
et pour parler de la situation texas
mais aussi plus globalement aux etats
unis nous sommes en direct depuis new
york avec shadwick louhans journaliste
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir shadwick mot merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france à l'instant
il ya quelques secondes joe biden a
réagi et s'est levée de restrictions a
notamment évidemment au texas les
qualifiant d' une pensée préhistorique
on voit qu'il ya une guerre qui
s'instaure entre le président qui veut
faire de la lutte anti qu'ovide sa
priorité il l'a toujours dit et certains
gouverneurs qui n'entendent pas les
choses de la même façon d'être aux états
comme la floride qui s'érigent est a eu
lieu à des mois qui s'est débarrassée
des masques
il y avait et il n'y a pas eu de
catastrophe à la réouverture dans le
texas et un autre pays qui un autre état
qui récupère sa liberté et d'autres
trucs avec la géorgie le suivent sans
être aussi conclu que c'est un pays très
bien mais pas très peuplée et la
californie ont également se trouvent
dans des situations où nous allions
finir dans les trois états clés ya qu'on
peut sortir mais la vie est très
différente auparavant et pourtant elle
convient de toujours là toujours des
hospitalisations et des décès les
résultats montrent en floride et dans
d'autres états que ce confinement ne
fait que blesser l'économie et
la santé psychique des gens elle je
batte elle n'aime pas parler de cela
mais il y à plus d'utilisateurs de
drogue il ya plus de suicides isolement
dans sucre c'est genre depuis plus d'un
an
très dur va commencer par dire qu'il
fasse confinés pendant quelques mois
pour ralentir la propagation et
maintenant cela fait un an les états
républicains forte et sans suivre leur
propre foi et c'est la façon système
fonctionne aux états unis chad reed
moore c'est finalement deux visions se
sont finalement deux visions qui
s'affrontent
peut-être celle des démocrates et celle
des républicains ça nous rappelle en
tout cas clairement la campagne
présidentielle où donald trump et et
voilà pour les libertés pour maintenir
l'économie une certaine forme de liberté
publique oppose évidemment la vision de
joe biden fait ça pendant la campagne de
jouer message républicain et démocrate
était très différent le message que
donald trump été aussi ce qu'il voulait
aller de l'avant progresser avancé
réouvrir aussi rapidement que possible
relancer l'économie et remettre les
enfants à l'école
le message de joe madden avant son
éviction était celui d'un univers sombre
avenir
lisez que la situation est devenue pire
avant de s'améliorer ces deux visions
des deux parties effectivement sont
aussi résumé très simplement
il ya beaucoup de pression sur vos pas
et n
pour que les écoles restent fermées mais
bien sûr cela et voit le chèque
les parents démocrates comme des
républicains veulent que leurs enfants
en revenant à l'école parce que les
écoles rouvrent et joe biden a commencé
à dire que au niveau fédéral il allait
suggérer que les professeurs soient
priorisées pour la vaccination
donc effectivement ce sont deux visions
des deux partis le parti républicain
veut plus de liberté rouvrir l'économie
l'autre parti le parti démocrate veut un
confinement est en elle démasque les uns
sur les autres
1 2 3 30 masques apporter à la fois il
ya des personnalités par exemple comme
anthony fochi qu'ils sont aimés par les
démocrates est détesté par les
républicains doutre personnes lisent le
confinement pourrait durer encore un an
pourrait durer jusqu'en 2022 avant que
la situation redevienne normale
les républicains acceptent est passé là
donc c'est vraiment la grande fracture
des visions de ce pays entre deux
approches deux parties la façon qu'ils
voient le meilleur moyen d'avancer et
cela se cristallise autour de la réponse
la coved alors en tout cas de joe biden
essaye de tenir ses promesses et veulent
mettre le paquet dans la lutte contre le
coc vide le président qui vient
d'annoncer que l'objectif de vaccination
pour tous les adultes et bien ce serait
finalement fin mai avait plus joué à la
faveur de l'accord avec johnson &
johnson c'est un objectif qui est très
ambitieux comment est il perçu aux états
unis avaient effectivement commencé par
dire un fin juillet ce qui avait amassé
au prix et
c'est maintenant de la loi sur la
production de défense pour essayer de
raccourcir le calendrier jusqu'à la fin
mais il bénéficie des efforts de donald
femmes concernant les respirateurs les
équipant de protection personnelle
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais autour de
moi les gens ne sont pas très
enthousiastes
les gens en ont marre de la commune il
veut plus en parler autour de moi les
gens en bonne santé qui veulent à tout
prix ce vaccin sont une petite minorité
très brillante la majorité des gens même
dans des lieux très lisible comme new
york
cela m'inquiète c'est des fariboles et
il continue de suivre cette politique de
porter le masque parce que c'est ce
qu'on est censé faire parce que c'est ce
que le gouvernement gentil et le
gouvernement ce n'est que tout le monde
donc la vaccination et d'issia ça mais
c'est en bleu mais les gens ne s'y
intéresse pas trop ils sont prêts à
reprendre la vie normale des
républicains de leur propre chef les
démocrates quand les allemands le dira
ça veut dire clairement chalvet debout
que aux états unis c'est bon c'est cas
voilà c'est très grand les états unis
bien sûr et qu'il ya certainement
différentes opinions mais contrairement
à l'europe les gens ne sont pas si
demandeurs que ça quant à la vaccination
parce que évidemment ici on râle
beaucoup à cause des pénuries des
vaccins vous ne ressentez pas la même
chose aux états unis sans doute un peu
plus de scepticisme envers le vaccin les
états unis mais même aux états unis
il y a des gens qui sont influençables
qui suivent l'autorité de très près je
ne pense pas que l'obligation de se
faire vacciner serait acceptée aux états
unis mais certaines industries certaines
entreprises pourrait demander à 25 ligue
at war par exemple les compagnies
aériennes et est les américains seraient
forcés de suivre car elle ne pourrait
pas normal c'est en cela que nous sommes
pas en passe d'avoir des murs et de
bâtons la distribution se passe au
départ cela semblait difficile par
exemple à new york
on entendait parler de vaccins qu'il
terminait à la poubelle parce qu'on ne
réussissez pas à les conserver et à les
distribuer correctement le qu'il ya sans
doute plus de scepticisme aux états unis
mais c'est une simple différence
culturelle entre les états unis et
d'autres pays les gens aux états unis
est sont plus confortables avec l'idée
d'une homme était naturel sachant que
cela signifie tombé malade de la commune
se remettent un curé être protégé plutôt
que de devoir se faire injecter un
vaccin développé en un temps record et
qui pour beaucoup de personnes semble
encore assez expérimental sachant que
certains vaccins ont nécessité des
décennies à être développé donc il ya
sept ce scepticisme comprend beaucoup de
personnes la cohue 19 qui n'est pas si
effrayante que ça sauf pour les
personnes très malades ou très âgés et
cela peut influencer les décisions aux
états unis merci beaucoup shadwick moi
j'en ai is politique nous avoir exposé
donc la situation aux états unis pour vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
mobilisation anti pashinian d'ampleur
une nouvelle fois devant le parlement à
erevan la crise politique s'enlise en
arménie à l'opposition refusant toujours
à la tenue de nouvelles élections
anticipées
on fait le point avec notre reporter sur
place david kelly fa nouveau
rassemblement anti pashinian sous haute
tension ici un millier de personnes
présentes devant le parlement encadrés
par un important dispositif de sécurité
un impressionnant dispositif de sécurité
on peut même dire à chaque coin de rue
ou presque
à travers la ville on a pu apercevoir
adea patrouille de police à savoir que
devant chaque bâtiment administratif
la sécurité a été renforcée et ici
autour du parlement
plus d'une dizaine de cars de policiers
a déployé afin d'assurer la sécurité à
dieu parlement à savoir qu'un sniper et
est même disposé à l'une des fenêtres du
bâtiment gouvernemental la raison la
présence de nicolas pashinian au sein à
du parlement arménien il répondait
aujourd'hui aux questions des députés
concernant la crise politique que
traverse le pays
le premier ministre arménien a réitéré
sa demande d'élections législatives
anticipées écoutez si l'opposition
parlementaire accepte notre proposition
nous aurons une opportunité d'organiser
des élections anticipées dans les délais
convenus cours en 2021
les élections sont un moyen de rétablir
la solidarité sociale
les autorités doivent être le garant des
élections justes et libres
j'envisage une réunion avec les
représentants et l'opposition
parlementaire
une demande restée pour l'heure sans
réponse de la part de l'opposition
parlementaire mais qui ne satisfait
toujours pas
léa nombreux manifestants présents ici
un depuis jeudi dernier leur objectif
est toujours le même le départ de nikol
pashinian considéré comme un traître
considéré comme un paria depuis la
défaite militaire dans le haut-karabagh
vécue comme une véritable humilis
humiliation nationale pour la plupart
des manifestants la présente devant le
parlement arménien leur souhait un
gouvernement de transition jusqu'aux
prochaines élections l'an prochain et si
élections anticipées il doit y avoir
elles deux
vrai à se faire sans la présence de
nikol pashinian écouter à plusieurs
partisans anti un premier ministre
arménien en effet ce n'est pas une
proposition du premier ministre
c'est notre exigence qui nous a tous
réunis ici nous exigeons la démission du
premier ministre
nous exigeons de former un nouveau
gouvernement de transition et de tenir
des élections parlementaires anticipées
maintenant les autorités c'est de
changer de sujet et de faire comme si
elles soient d organiser des élections
alors que nous n'en voulons pas nous
disons mais si il faut absolument
organiser des élections dans le pays et
le peuple doit décider qui présidera le
gouvernement dans l'avenir je suis en
désaccord avec ce qui se produit chez
nous actuellement
le peuple est en désaccord on ne peut
pas agir comme ça on ne peut pas réunir
les gens pour les diriger contre leurs
compatriotes ce serait la guerre civile
j'estime que ce n'est pas juste
j'estime qu'en fin de compte les
élections auront lieu mais sans nicole
pashinian il n'y a pas d'autre solution
il doit partir et c'est tout la
manifestation s'est en tout cas déroulée
sans heurts une nouvelle fois ici devant
le parlement arménien malgré les
nombreuses provocations qui ont émergé à
sur les réseaux sociaux
d'où ce dispositif de sécurité beaucoup
plus conséquent que les précédentes
journées
à savoir que le président arménien a
reçu ce matin les leaders de
l'opposition pour éluder la question du
limogeage du chef d'état-major de
l'armée une demande souvenez vous faites
par le premier ministre refusé à deux
reprises par le président l'opposition a
demandé à armen sarkissian de porter l
affaire devant le conseil
constitutionnel afin de ne pas céder à
cette motion problème il ne peut pas
contourner la loi arménienne même en
saisissant ce conseil qui ne peut rien
faire
ainsi c'est inscrit dans la constitution
arménienne le chef de l'état se retrouve
donc face à une impasse et va devoir
accepter cette demande du premier
ministre arménien le chef d'état major
devrait donc a priori acquis t elle son
poste avant la fin de la semaine ce qui
devrait accentuer un peu plus la crise
politique que traverse le pays arménien
la russie réagi après les sanctions
américaines à l'encontre de sept hauts
responsables russes dans le cas de
faire navalni elle appelle les états
unis à ne pas jouer avec le feu l'union
européenne a pour sa part officialiser
lundi des sanctions contre quatre hauts
fonctionnaires russes la correspondance
à moscou d'antoine frérot comme on
pouvait s'y attendre les sanctions
adoptée par bruxelles et washington dans
le cadre de la sphère navalni ont été
fermement dénoncée par le kremlin qui y
voit une ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures du pays les autorités qui
juge scandaleuses les accusations qui
tiennent le fsb pour responsables de
l'empoisonnement supposé de l'opposant
russe
elles ont d'ailleurs promis de répondre
à ces sanctions en temps et en heure
évidemment ces sanctions ne resteront
pas sans réponse c'est évident la
réponse correspondra de la meilleure
façon à nos propres intérêts nous allons
convenir de sanctions présenter nos
propositions à la direction pour
signature
et une fois approuvées elles seront
annoncées nous en informerons ensuite
nos adversaires mais entendre le
porte-parole du kremlin il s'agit au
final d'un non événement en effet les
personnes ciblées par les sanctions sont
des haut fonctionnaires qui de toute
façon n'ont que peu ou pas de contacts
avec des pays tiers
ces gens là ne vont de toute façon pas à
l'étranger n'ont pas le droit d'ouvrir
les comptes dans les banques étrangères
d'avoir des biens à l'étranger et cetera
cela n'est pas appliqué un certain
nombre de personnes morales et qui y
figurent également
mais ce n'est pas ce qui compte
nous estimons que toute restriction de
ce type est tout à fait inadmissible
parce qu'elle nuit sensiblement aux
relations qui sont déjà dans un état
déplorable
en l'occurrence les relations avec les
états unis et avec l'union européenne
ce n'est qu'une ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures de la russie ce
n'est pas à nous d'expliquer leur
motivation que ce soit des restrictions
ponctuelle ou pas
de manière générale nous estimons que
les décisions de ce type sont absurdes
et dépourvue de fondement
et ce qui est le plus important elles
n'ont ni effet me sens à cet égard nous
ne pouvons qu'exprimer notre regret
notre perplexité
même si au final ces sanctions revêtent
avant tout un caractère symbolique
elles ne font que dégrader des relations
déjà au plus bas entre moscou et les
capitales occidentales
ailleurs dans le monde en a également
réagi à ces annonces et sans surprise
londres a accueilli positivement ces
nouvelles sanctions tandis que la chine
a dénoncé ce qu'elle considère être une
ingérence dans d affaire strictement
interne à la russie et pour en parler
nous sommes avec karine 1b chez écolo
fco professeur invité à l'université
d'état de moscou bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ses fonctions à spa nous
aurons un réel impact ont finalement
est-ce plus symbolique
bonsoir ces sanctions dans quoi
strictement aucun impact sur la
politique intérieure en russie et ça de
manière les états unis le savent
parfaitement
simplement les états unis utilisent leur
soft power
parce que les sanctions sont un moyen de
pression lance un message politique non
seulement au pays au classement dressé
mais également aux autres pays en les
obligeant s'est positionné vous êtes
avec nous ou vous êtes contre nous et
c'est en ce sens que la politique de
sanctions systématiques qui est mise en
oeuvre par les états unis qui en qui
emmène en fait en ligne européenne sur
cette voie est une politique de deux
combats pour faire plier la russie
d'ailleurs la grande bretagne à l'onu
l'a parfaitement préciser quand elle a
dit que les relations du monde
occidental avec la russie vont dépendre
des décisions politiques de la russie
c'est exactement ce qu'il dit soit la
russie se plie aux dictats pts
occidentale et dans ce cas là une partie
des sanctions pourraient être allégées
mais la paix la russie comme pays
n'existera plus
soit la russie continue à défendre son
international
et effectivement nous sommes dans une
phase de confrontation idéologique donc
c'est tout à fait normal alors moscou
rappelle à les états unis à ne pas jouer
avec le feu que doit-on comprendre par
ces paroles qu'est ce qui pourrait se
passer
la russie a certes beaucoup de patience
et l'a montré jusqu'à présent mais c'est
un pays souvent et qui entend défendre
sa souveraineté politique elle le fait
comprendre la nouvelle administration
maidana a exprimé par la boisson
secrétaire d'état un changement soit
disant en tout cas annoncées dans le
cours politique américain qui ne voit
plus un intérêt à recourir aux conflits
armés long et cher contre les régimes
qu'ils n'estiment pas démocratique
manifestement ils veulent utiliser la
politique de sanctions dans le cadre de
du retour à la politique continuant qui
était à l'époque mais en oeuvre contre
l'union soviétique la russie évidemment
de son côté ne peut pas laisser faire
c'est une question non seulement de
prestige mais c'est aussi une question
de survie politique parce que plus l'on
montre de signes de faiblesse puis en
face votre adversaire va taper fort donc
effectivement ça ne veut pas dire que la
russie doivent répondre absolument
symétriquement puisque les intérêts des
deux pays sont différents mais c'était
la russie de déterminer strictement un
cours stratégie qui pour l'instant n'est
pas très très clairs et de montrer aussi
quelles sont les frontières parce que le
fait de poser des frontières en
expliquant clairement quelle sera sa
stratégie ça peut avoir aussi un effet
dissuasif ce que pour l'instant n'est
pas extrêmement visible alors les
sanctions occidentales
peuvent-elles dégrader encore davantage
les relations avec la russie comme
semble d'ailleurs le
dire clairement moscou on aurait
tendance à penser que les relations sont
tellement mauvaise qu'il soit difficile
que cela soit encore pire
mais manifestement les européens et les
américains mettent quand même beaucoup
d'efforts effectivement trouvé un moyen
pour les dégradés de plus en plus
donc oui effectivement il est tout à
fait possible que ce que ces relations
se dégradent encore même si la russie ne
cesse de répéter que de son côté elle ne
prendra pas l'initiative de la rupture
des relations
il serait quand même intelligent en tout
cas de la part des pays européens qu'il
se souvient de leurs propres intérêts
stratégiques qui est celui d'une
coopération avec la russie ce qui ne
veut pas dire de partager tous les
points de vue mais ce qui veut dire de
maintenir un dialogue constructif ce qui
pour l'instant fait défaut puisque tout
le dialogue entre l'europe et la russie
est entre les mains de l'union
européenne qui est manifestement en tout
cas ouvertement actuellement deux
structures qui défend les intérêts de
matisse et non pas les intérêts
européens
au nom de quelle base juridique de quel
texte de quelle institution
ces gouvernements prend-il des sanctions
contre la russie qu'elle en fait il faut
comprendre que aussi étrangement que
cela puisse paraître les sanctions entre
un pays et un autre pays sont des
mesures qui ressort de la souveraineté
de ce pays c'est à dire que vous avez le
droit d'interdire certaines choses à un
autre pays sur votre territoire puisque
vous êtes maître de votre territoire
dont vous décidez ce qui s'y passe en
revanche là où les sanctions américaines
ou européennes et surtout américaines
dans la logique à vendre à l'encontre de
cette règle tout à fait logique
c'est lorsqu'il condamne deux tiers pays
pour les sanctions que eux prennent à
l'encontre de la russie c'est à dire que
les personnes qui ne sont pas en russie
et qui ne sont pas aux états unis qui ne
respectent pas les sanctions américaines
contre la russie qui porte une
responsabilité devant les états unis
ça c'est une logique impériale
ce qui va complètement à l'inversé de la
logique souverainiste merci beaucoup
karine abéché call of qu au professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou
d'avoir été avec nous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur la situation sanitaire en france
gabriel attal donne un peu d'espoir aux
français aujourd'hui il espère un retour
à une vie plus normale peut-être dès la
mi-avril et puis ces annonces ce soir
l'île de france ne serait a priori pas
confiner le week end c'est ce qu'on
apprend de source gouvernementale
seul le département du pas de calais
serait confiné le week-end on y
reviendra on ira aussi au brésil
examinez de la situation sur le front du
coc vide
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier
à quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je
j'essaie de faire au mieux c'est aussi
tout un questionnement sur la société
sur le rapport à la solidarité et le
commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois ci il faut un
évidemment
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire aurait creusé encore
un peu plus les inégalités entre eux et
plus riches et les plus pauvres il y à
un million de pauvres en plus on est
passé de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim nous ne sommes pas en
france on a l'impression d'être en train
de passer dans un pays du tiers-monde
le problème il est bien en amont il est
depuis que les banques centrales
intrigues de l'argent et quand l intérim
de l'argent en fait ça ne va pas dans
l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
la cause de la paupérisation de la
france de la tiers mondisation sur
laquelle on s'engage si la destruction
de l'industrie française
réindustrialiser c'est pas juste en
claquant des doigts vous faites revenir
les sociétés d'abord il faut changer
complètement tout c'est à dire tout ce
qui les a fait partir il ya une débauche
d'argent qu'on met sur le sur la table
sans se préoccuper de savoir qui au
final va payer au final c'est toujours
les mêmes les dindons de la farce c'est
toujours les mêmes vertus on va se
tourner pour aller payer la note
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même un
certain lien de confiance est rompu
entre le politique et les experts et
même les citoyens on est une société qui
est totalement percuté et on ne peut pas
considérer une démocratie vit
véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment on repart à
zéro par rapport à l'année dernière
la société ne survivra pas à une
succession de confinement une société
c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
comment on va réorganiser le monde il
est vrai que la pandémie c'est vivre
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france pour cette
deuxième émission tout de suite voici
les titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
3 mars un horizon et des restrictions
l'exécutif prévoit des semaines de gros
temps mais espère un retour à une vie
plus normale peut être dès la mi-avril
conférence de presse de jean castex
attendu ce jeudi à 18 heures si une
vingtaine de départements sont sous
surveillance renforcée depuis une
semaine le pas de calais serait le seul
à être confiné le week end
outre atlantique le brésil deuxième pays
au monde le plus endeuillé par le cos
vide les systèmes de santé de plusieurs
états fédérés sont au bord de
l'effondrement des gouverneurs ont
instauré des couvre-feux et fermer les
commerces non essentiel en dépit du
lourd bilan en vies humaines le pibe
brésilien reculé seulement de 4,1 pour
cent l'année dernière déjouant les
pronostics plus pessimistes au liban
un livre à son plus bas historique sur
le marché noir la devise du pays du
cèdre a frôlé les 10 mille livres pour
un dollar
les manifestants ont défilé hier soir
dans les rues de beyrouth pour exprimer
leur colère face à l'effondrement
économique couplée à la crise politique
et à la pandémie
[Musique]
emmanuel macron reconnaît la
responsabilité de la france dans
l'assassinât d'ali boumendjel en algérie
c'était le 23 mars 1957 en pleine
bataille d'alger
l'avocat proche du front de libération
nationale avait été arrêté par l'armée
française est placé au secret alors ce
geste permettra-t-il de relancer le
dialogue mais maurienne entre la france
et l'algérie ce sera l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
[Musique]
pas de confinement le week end à paris
et en ile de france a priori selon des
sources gouvernementales citées par l'
agence française presse ce soir le pas
de calais devrait être le seul
département confiné au week end des
décisions qui devraient être annoncés
officiellement demain ce matin en tout
cas à nouveau conseil de défense
sanitaire au menu notamment l'avenir
immédiat des vingt départements sous
surveillance renforcée
quand un mot clair la situation
épidémique a beau se dégrader dans
l'ensemble de l'hexagone
l'exécutif laisse entrevoir l'espoir
d'une amélioration durant les prochaines
semaines
ce mercredi le porte-parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent a évoqué un
possible retour à une vie plus normale
dès la mi-avril
je comprends que certains peinent à
trouver un sens à cette période soit
tenté de baisser les bras parce que la
lassitude est évidemment importante dans
la vie avec ce virus et les restrictions
que ce virus impose sur nos vies
quotidiennes mon message est clair
tenons bon ne nous résignons pas après
tant d'efforts nous allons affronter
encore des épreuves c'est vrai mais pour
la première fois depuis des mois
maintenant le retour à des vie plus
normale et en vue ne s'agit pas d'un
horizon lointain et incertain
il s'agit d'un horizon de plus en plus
proche peut-être nous l'espérons dès la
mi avril auquel nous nous préparons lors
du conseil de défense sanitaire de ce
mercredi l'exécutif s'est penché sur la
mise en place de restrictions
supplémentaires pour les vingt
départements placés en surveillance
renforcée un confinement le week-end et
notamment évoqué les municipalités de
paris et de marseille se sont déjà
positionnés contre cette mesure
al'inverse le préfet du pas-de-calais a
émis mardi soir le souhait de confiner
son département lors des trois prochains
week-ends la balle est désormais dans le
camp de matignon gabriel attal a
également déclaré ce mercredi que des
restrictions pourraient varier en
fonction des territoires
on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas une seule
solution d'abord parce que les
territoires sont différents et peuvent
appeler des réponses différentes
ensuite parce que s'il existait une
seule et unique solution clairement
identifiés qui à elle seule permet tait
de terrasser le virent
durablement je pense que cela fait
longtemps qu'elle aurait été adopté par
tous les pays du monde
confinera ou confinera pas le week end
les vingt départements surveillance
renforcée devrait en savoir plus lors de
la conférence de presse du gouvernement
de ce jeudi
comme à nice l'agglomération de
dunkerque est soumis à un confinement le
week-end de plus la semaine dernière le
taux d'incidence a dépassé les 1000 cas
positifs pour cent mille habitants en
début de semaine les hôpitaux sont
submergés
ils sont dans l'obligation d'organiser
des transferts de patients vers d'autres
régions
les transferts sont indispensables
puisque notre capacité de réanimation
est dépassé et là encore si on n'avait
pas le recours à l'aide régionale et
maintenant interrégional on serait dans
une très très grande difficulté et donc
c'est quelque chose absolument essentiel
enfin en guadeloupe plutôt épargnés par
les restrictions jusqu'à maintenant un
couvre-feu de 22 heures à 6 heures
entrera en vigueur dès dimanche les
salles de sport et salle d'exposition
seront également fermés à partir de
lundi la cause du flambée de cas de kovy
19 due à la présence du vaillant
britannique et d'un autre wagon non
identifiés sur le territoire et pour
évoquer la situation sanitaire en france
nous sommes avec enrique casalino chef
des urgences à l'hôpital bichat à paris
bonsoir enrique
merci d'être avec nous alors entre temps
on a eu des informations a priori de
source gouvernementale citée par l'
agence france-presse
pas de confinement globale ça on le
savait plus ou moins mais pas de
confinement non plus le week-end comme
beaucoup le craignent et en ile de
france et à paris c'est en tant que chef
des urgences d'un hôpital parisien une
décision que vous déplorez pouvez aussi
on se dit que l'intérêt de la population
et vérifie si un peu plus de liberté
dans un peu plus de la sortie avec le ni
les week-ends le feu va rester de facto
nous sommes quand même et et deux
châteaux nous sortir aujourd'hui c'est
très difficile de faire des pronostics
parce que tout est courbe qui avaient
été faites sont modifiées par le faire
il y à des interventions le portage du
mas taux d'utilisation qui parce que le
confinement la nuit chacun d'entre nous
sont restreints dans certaines règles
sociales ont rencontré les personnes
âgées ou en off aux habitants de
rencontrer certains de vos proches votre
vie sociale réduite donc toutes les tous
les modèles mathématiques on avait alors
nous ne marche plus donc c'est très
difficile de se prononcer il est vrai
que la situation est très tendue dans
les hôpitaux nous son temps qu'il y a et
semaine avec une petite diminution et
des semaines avec une petite
augmentation et notre grosse crainte
c'est qu'à un moment les choses au pis
s'emballer et que notre capacité de
réserve n'existe pas au merlan pas une
capacité de réserve suffisante
aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux les
départements qui sont très touchées
actuellement pour pouvoir répondre un
afflux massif de patients
effectivement plus de 3600 personnes
atteintes de comme il était soigné en
réanimation
ce soir soit le chiffre le plus haut
depuis fin novembre c'est quelque chose
que nous arriver
a expliqué la faute aux variants oui il
ya le marion qui expliquent une partie
leur hargne ont un avantage de génétique
et il s'est imposé aujourd'hui en région
parisienne plus de 60 x 80 % des
patients infectés sont infectés par anne
des variantes donc il s'est imposé ils
expliquent une partie de l'augmentation
du nombre de cas le danger c'est que une
fois qu'il a appris la place de tous les
virus lui il continue à survoler à son
volet et je comprends que nos
compatriotes nos concitoyens sont
épuisés en même temps la france est un
grand pays et chacun d'entre nous doit
faire preuve de son engagement dans
l'intérêt collectif dans l'intérêt de
toute la population au protéger chacun
chacun de leurs êtres chers c'est cet
indispensable cet engagement de chacun
protéger toute la population le labo
vide c'est pas une maladie banale même
pour les personnes qui n'ont pas fait
d'effort le gramme il ya des
conséquences à moyen et long terme pour
les personnes qui peut faire des formes
graves
c'est une épreuve difficile
l'étouffement la difficulté respiratoire
être en réanimation est loin d'être
anodin que ce que l'animateur à la base
j'ai travaillé pendant des années en
réanimation
c'est une épreuve chacun des patients
donc ce n'est pas quelque chose d'anodin
notre rôle est de protéger tous nos
concitoyens et pour cela malgré les
progrès dans la vaccination nous devons
continuer à respecter réel de
distanciation les règles barrière c'est
un engagement civique essentiel de
chacun d'entre nous justement c'est bien
que vous le rappeliez henrique casalino
parce qu'on a un petit peu le sentiment
de pas de france mais voilà un camp qui
on peut pas parler de camp mais voilà
une partie de la population qui semble
très loin de ce virus peut-être voilà
qui fait quand des personnes plus jeunes
ne voit pas ce virus le gouvernement qui
tente quand même de nous encourager
qui dit que les premiers effets de la
vaccination se font sentir qu'ils voient
une sortie de crise peut-être à la mi
avril et cette situation vous nous
décrivez dans les services d'urgences
avec des chiffres qui sont inquiétants
vous comment vous vous situez vous êtes
plutôt aussi dans le camp quand même des
optimistes la fin du tunnel c'est pour
bientôt pour vous suis bien sûr le
ministre et je suis plein de courage ou
et plein d'enthousiasmé je suis certain
que l'immense majorité des français
c'est vrai ça n'empêche que nous devons
être réalistes aujourd'hui nous devons
continuer à respecter les règles de
distanciation
nous devons nous engager tous pour
maxime et tous nos concitoyens qui ont
des critères de fragilité qui nécessite
une vaccination sont les premiers qui
vont aux baissiers
nous devons continuer à protéger les
personnes les plus fragiles en faisant
très attention pour l'ebit fit l
attention de garder la distance de
porter le masque faut surtout pas penser
que le combat est gagné d avance
aucun combat n'est gagné d'avancé et
nous devons continuer même si l'horizon
paraît un peu plus serein avec l'idée de
l'arrivée des beaux jours
dès le mois d'avril nous allons rester
raisonnable très prudent et les pays où
l'épidémie est très importante on malgré
le fait qu'il fait chaud regardez le
brésil c'est un très bon exemple
ce qui est arrivé dans le département
d'amazones amazonas au brésil il fait
chaud
et pourtant les billets mis à flamber
donc nous devons être extrêmement
prudent continuer respecter les règles
et être très engagé pour nous protéger
nous mail est protégée l'ensemble d'un
cycle
dernière question clé évidemment c c'est
une des clés principales mais pas que
les vaccins astrazeneca
ça n'a pas donné les résultats qu'on
attendait puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
réticences même
y compris chez les soignants johnson and
johnson on attend la semaine prochaine
une idée cela peut changer la donne pour
vous il y a eu une mauvaise information
sur le versant d'astrazeneca
il ya eu désinformation d'abord sur des
effets indésirables signalés cet
indésirable
rien d'extraordinaire il a eu une
mauvaise information et désinformation
concernant son éventuelle non efficacité
sur le maillot sud-africain
ça a été aussi finalement un peu
contesté aujourd'hui tous les vaccins se
valent aujourd'hui la priorité c'est de
se vacciner
je pense que notre conseil doit être de
bien aux français va signer vous avec le
mc5 on vous propose qui est disponible
c'est celui là qui est le bon il est là
et vous allez en bénéficier tous ces
vaccins sont très efficaces ils
protègent et il est évident que ce n'est
pas parce que je suis vacciné je peux
lever toutes les mesures de prévention
de distanciation social effet barrière
de geste l'arrière pour me protéger moi
et pour protéger toutes les personnes
aujourd'hui porter le masque garder la
distance respecter les personnes de ce
que je rentre dans un endroit où je me
balade dans la rue en portant le masque
celle-ci de respect c'est un signe
d'engagement un signe d'amour pour les
personnes qui sont avec moi et je me
dois de continuer le faire même si c'est
contraignant même si ces crédits fixés
c'est difficile je peux le comprendre
nous sommes un grand pays me sens une
grande nation chacun d'entre nous peut
être fier d'être ici
ils ne vont continuer à respecter ses
règles pour notre intérêt dont
entraînerait dans l'intérêt de tous
leurs concitoyens
merci beaucoup a indiqué qu'un salino
chef des urgences à l'hôpital bichat à
paris d'avoir été avec no et après les
parlementaires qui ont rendu en décembre
un rapport dénonçant la gestion
défaillante de la pandémie est mince au
tour des citoyens et associations de
demandes
l'état de rendre des comptes une action
judiciaire collective a donc été engagée
pour demander diverses documents liés à
la crise sanitaire le tribunal
judiciaire de paris examine à partir
d'aujourd'hui leur requête les
précisions d'estelle farges
les autorités sanitaires ont elle agit
efficacement contre l'épidémie de kovy
19 y at il eu certains manquements c'est
à ces questions qu'un groupe de 60
citoyens principalement des familles de
résidents en ehpad ainsi que cinq
associations souhaitent avoir des
réponses pour cela ils ont déposé une
demande en référé au tribunal judiciaire
de paris
plus globalement ils souhaitent
comprendre l'absence de masques au
premier semestre de l'année 2020 mais
aussi les critères qui ont permis
l'hospitalisation ou non de personnes
âgées atteint du coc vite 19è certains
dénoncent aussi l'utilisation du
rivotril dans des ehpad je propose
d'écouter ces témoignages qui a les
dimensions donc collectivement on
demande des comptes sur les masques ou
tri des malades et reçu de spi et
individuellement chacun d'entre nous
donc familles associations soient des
associations avec nous bien sûr on
implique nos directeurs de structures
moi mon directeur d'ehpad au delà
d'avoir menti il n'a pas répondu à mes
questions
on doit
savoir ce qui s'est passé il doit y
avoir de la transparence il droit d'y
avoir l'avenue d'idées sans transparence
il n'y a pas de confiance
voilà pourquoi moi aujourd'hui s'y
engager ma mère est décédée le 4 avril
elle est décédée
je pense à la suite de dury votre hymne
qui lui a été administré la veille au
soir
sans notre consentement sans le sien non
plus
il s'agit pour eux d'une première étape
il souhaite que la justice ordonne la
transmission de divers documents de la
part d'organismes de santé comme des
hôpitaux et des ehpad mais aussi la rs
l'agencé régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france le but examiné eux mêmes
tous ces documents pour éventuellement
intenter des actions je vous propose
d'écouter l'avocat des requérants c'est
ce qu'on appelle un référé probatoire il
s'agit de réunir des preuves des
informations qui permettront ensuite
d'orienter une éventuelle action en
justice
et ça va dépendre un petit peu d'époque
nous allons récupérer
monsieur caussimont a perdu sa maman
l'année dernière dans un ehpad à pantin
et il a l'impression que c'était pas de
l'ehpad et toutes les informations
concernant les codes ou les deux
la fin de vie de sa maman donc par cette
procédure il espère récupérer bien
évidemment d'abord le rapport médical le
dossier médical mais surtout il veut
vérifier que la procédure mise en place
par la loi claisse leonetti sur la fin
de vie a été respectée parce que
monsieur cause aussi mon n'a pas été
consulté pour le placement sous rivotril
de sa maman or le rivotril c'est un
produit extrêmement puissant dont
l'objectif final est de placer un
sédation profonde terminale c'est à dire
d'amener dallas mort une personne c'est
un exemple de questions qui vont se
poser aujourd'hui le tribunal judiciaire
de paris se penche donc sur cette action
aujourd'hui d'après leur avocat ils
s'attendent à une mise en délibéré
la bosnie aidé par son ancien ennemi et
la serbie fait un don de 10 mille doses
de strazeele et cas destinés aux
personnels soignants bosniaque et
bosnie-herzégovine est l'un des rares
pays au monde à ne pas avoir lancé sa
campagne de vaccination il comptait sur
le mécanisme onusien kovacs on recevoir
des vaccins mais les délais de livraison
sont constamment repoussée quentin
mauclair longtemps attendue des doses de
vaccin arrive enfin en
bosnie-herzégovine
cette livraison inespérée de dix mille
doses du sérum d'astrazeneca correspond
à un don de la serbie à son voisin
balkanique qui a du mal à
s'approvisionner 5000 membres du
personnel médical pourront ainsi être
vaccinés en priorité aux sétois accès
cadart dans une situation les mécanismes
globaux et multilatéraux
d'approvisionnement en vaccins et échoué
le président voudrait nous a envoyé ce
ghana nous l'avons acceptée je le
remercie watchers les factures les haies
et en faire un potager dont la tante de
serre romantique au vide
la bosnie n'a toujours pas pu lancer sa
campagne de vaccination dans le même
temps le pays dispose d'un des taux de
mortalité lié au co vide des plus élevés
au monde
sarajevo comme belgrade a subi les
défaillances du mécanisme onusien
d'acquisition de vaccins
kovacs nous nous attendions à recevoir
des vaccins de lui mais nous ne les
avons pas reçu les avez vous reçu ici à
sarajevo
vous n'avez rien reçu nous avons obtenu
à belgrade
non nous n'avons rien reçu nous les
remercions lorsque nous recevrons des
vaccins du programme kovacs en mars ou
en avril
lorsque cela se produira en bosnie
chaque région gère elle même ses
commandes de vaccins candidats
potentiels à une adhésion à l'union
européenne
la bosnie herzégovine est depuis 1995 et
les accords de dayton scindé en trois
parties la fédération de bosnie
herzégovine région croato musulmane où
les relations avec la serbie ne sont que
formel c'est pourtant dans cette région
que le don de dix mille vaccin
d'astrazeneca sera distribué ensuite la
république serbe de bosnie entité serbe
qui se veut plus proche de moscou et de
belgrade
cette région s'est d'ailleurs vu livré
ce lundi vingt mille doses du vaccin
russe coûte nick v et enfin le district
de brcko territoire autonome et neutre
cascadeur et la république serbe de
bosnie obtient ses vaccins d'une manière
différente du système kovacs tout comme
le ministre l'a dit dans le cadre de
kovacs nous avons payé pour deux cent
mille citoyen 400 mille doses de vaccin
nous avons également payer pour acquérir
quatre cent mille doses auprès de la
fédération de russie et nous avons une
promesse de l'union européenne et nous
travaillons également avec les chinois
pour obtenir des doses du vaccin chinois
en attendant qu'un million deux cent
mille doses de vaccin soit livrée par le
mécanisme kovacs la bosnie doit
multiplier les commandes pour enrayer
l'épidémie en lui apportant leur aide
les serpents de la main aux bosniens ce
geste pourrait bien permettre aux deux
pays d'améliorer leurs relations
belgrade à d'ailleurs annoncé avoir
proposé un sommet bilatéral dans les
prochains
dans le but de développer notamment une
coopération économique
le brésil traverse sa pire période
depuis le début de l'épidémie des
systèmes de santé de plusieurs états
fédérés sont en bord de l'effondrement
une situation qui a conduit les
gouverneurs a instauré des couvre-feux
et à fermer les commerces non essentiels
ont fait le point avec amaya souple et
le brésil enregistre un triste record ce
mardi avec 1641 décès en 24 heures lié
aux kovy 19 selon les autorités
sanitaires brésiliennes la pandémie ne
régresse pas dans le pays et elle
connaît même une nouvelle phase de
hausse des contaminations de plus en
plus d'hôpitaux sont saturés et la
propagation des variants ne rassure en
rien pour les mois à venir avec
l'arrivée des variantes du coc vide
il va être très difficile d'éviter les
effets immunologiques et réinfection et
cela soulève des questions sur
l'obtention d'une immunité collective
contre les infections naturel les
hôpitaux sont contraints de placer des
patients à l'extérieur en raison du
manque de place mais également de louer
des conteneurs réfrigérés
car les morgues sont submergés par le
nombre de victimes
cette situation critique a poussé
plusieurs états du pays à durcir les
restrictions les gouverneurs instaure
des couvre-feux et ferme les commerces
non essentiels seule exception à la
règle
rio de janeiro la ville connaît une
baisse du taux d'infection de 40%
un chiffre qui a poussé les autorités
locales à assouplir les mesures
sanitaires
le brésil est le pays le plus endeuillé
au monde derrière les états unis avec
257 1300 morts pour 212 millions
d'habitants la campagne de vaccination
peine à prendre de l'ampleur
seulement 3,8 pour cent de la population
a reçu une première injection de
nombreux états ont dû suspendre
l'administration des doses à cause du
manque de vaccins
dans le reste de l'actualité en turquie
le procès par contumace autour de
l'assassinât du journaliste saoudien
racho guy reprendre ce jeudi à istanbul
vingt personnes sont jugées pour meurtre
jamal khashoggi et résidant aux états
unis a été assassiné le 2 octobre 2018
dans le consulat saoudien à istanbul par
un commando son corps démembré n'a
jamais été retrouvé après avoir nié
d'assassinât riad a fini par admettre
qu'il avait été commis par des agents
saoudiens ayant agi seul et hier
reporters sans frontières a déposé
plainte en allemagne contre l'humanité
contre le prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite
et c'est dans ce contexte qu'une enquête
de mediapart a révélé que la conseillère
du premier ministre jean castex mais
hélas boulot ça un temps assurer la
promotion de l'arabie saoudite
les détails avec katia technique la
conseillère du premier ministre jean
castex mayada boulos a un temps fait du
lobbying pour l'arabie saoudite
elle était alors durant quatre ans et
jusqu'en 2020 directrice générale
adjointe de la grande agence havas
interrogé par mediapart a qui n'ont pas
échappé ses anciennes fonctions
la conseillère s'est défendue de toute
mission sur le domaine régalien où la
diplomatie
il s'agissait de faire connaître un site
historique et culturel ses monuments et
les activités notamment la découverte du
désert et la création à venir d'un musée
que la région pouvait offrir aux
touristes étrangers dans le futur mayada
boulos assurer la promotion du site
archéologique des lula elle explique ne
pas avoir oeuvré pour le compte de ryad
mais pour une fondation appartenant au
prince mohammed bin salman un site
stratégique aussi pour la france puisque
le prince avait décidé d'y investir 50
milliards de dollars pour attirer les
touristes internationaux et la france
est l un des partenaires et des
aménageurs de ce site exceptionnel
une merveille qui ne fait pas oublier
aux médias la réputation qu'ils accolent
au royaume
sept petites aspérités au milieu du
lumineux
cv de mayada boulos dans les cabinets
ministériels et les grandes agences de
communication avait été débusquée par le
magazine marianne en mai 2019
elle aurait était pressenti pour
remplacer le communicant sylvain fort à
l'elysée des proches du dossier
interviewé par l'hebdomadaire ont
expliqué à marianne qu'elle aurait
décliné pour des raisons d'organiser et
non en raison de son ancienne
collaboration matignon at il été
perturbé par cette mission les services
du premier ministre n'ont pas répondu à
nos sollicitations sur la question en
tout cas on s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas
toujours mal vue d'avoir travaillé pour
une puissance étrangère
suivez mon regard l'arabie saoudite
reste un client important de la france
notre pays étant l'un de ses
fournisseurs d'armes les plus importants
dont certaines sont suspectés de servir
dans le conflit avec le yémen
mais revenons au coeur du sujet l'arabie
saoudite est accusée de bombarder des
populations civiles yéménite ou d'avoir
caché le corps démembré d'un journaliste
dans une valise en même temps les
agences de lobbying dans différentes
parties du monde présente les atouts du
royaume
elle ne s'en sont pas toutes trop venté
msl la filiale de bruxelles ouest de
publicis chargé de cette communication
n'a pas déclaré le contrat avec son
encombrant client sur le registre de
transparence des activités de lobbying
mais cela ne les a pas empêchés de
travailler
réseaux sociaux organisation de
conférences l'observatoire européen du
lobbying le corporate europe observatory
a noté quels objectifs de transformation
du discours officiels saoudiens étaient
à l'oeuvre comme la promotion de la
popularité d'un mohamed ben salman
réformateur la volonté de faire oublier
les atteintes aux droits humains
en focalisant sur des avancées des
droits des femmes telles que la conduite
ainsi la teneur des articles concernant
l'arabie saoudite a évolué positivement
ces dernières années on découvre des
sujets sur le paris-dakar finances est
accueilli par le royaume sur les talents
de réformateurs du prince sans oublier
le fabuleux site d'al oula mise à
l'honneur par l'inénarrable jack lang
qui lui a réservé une exposition à
l'institut du monde arabe qu'il préside
al oula merveille d'arabie je vous parle
d'un site encore presque inconnu c'est
un site à la beauté flux grand car le
bing cible aussi les politiques certains
parlementaires français ont ainsi été
invités à visiter le centre de
commandement militaire de la coalition à
riad qui supervise la guerre au yémen
certaines personnalités politiques
françaises ne ménagent pas leurs efforts
pour préserver leurs relations avec le
royaume wahhabite par exemple rachida
dati et michèle alliot-marie membres de
la délégation du parlement européen pour
les relations avec la péninsule arabique
ont refusé en mai 2010huit de voter une
résolution condamnant les violences
sexistes en arabie saoudite
décidément mohamed ben salman peut
compter sur de nombreux soutiens
français qui ronronne jusque dans les
parlements et des ministères restez avec
nous nous reviendrons dans quelques
instants sur la situation au liban un
pays confronté à une crise politique
sanitaire et économique
les manifestants ont défilé hier soir
dans les rues de beyrouth pour exprimer
leur colère et puis nous parlerons d'
ali boumendjel emmanuel macron reconnaît
la responsabilité de la france dans son
assassinat en algérie c'était en mars
1957 en pleine bataille d'alger
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire aurait creusé encore
un peu plus les inégalités entre eux et
plus riches et les plus pauvres il y à
un million de pauvres en plus on est
passé de 9 à 10 millions de pauvres
on a 20 % des français qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim nous ne sommes pas en
france on a l'impression d'être en train
de passer dans un pays du tiers-monde le
problème il est bien en amont il est
depuis que les banques centrales
intrigues de l'argent et quand l intérim
de l'argent en fait ça ne va pas dans
l'économie réelle
ça va juste sur les marchés financiers
la cause de la paupérisation de la
france de la tiers mondisation sur
laquelle on s'engage si la destruction
de l'industrie française
réindustrialiser c'est pas juste en
claquant des doigts
vous faites revenir les sociétés d'abord
il faut changer complètement tout c'est
à dire tout ce qui les a fait partir il
ya un débauche d'argent qu'on met sur le
sur la table sans se préoccuper de
savoir qui au final va payer au final
c'est toujours les mêmes les dindons de
la farce c'est toujours les mêmes vertus
on va se tourner pour aller payer la
note
[Musique]
avec les accords d'abraham le président
américain reconnaît la souveraineté du
maroc sur le sahara en confiance
la france comme l'europe a été absente
de l'ensemble de cette négociation qui
impactent directement deux pays dans
lesquels nous avons des liens
privilégiés depuis fort longtemps la
république algérienne et le royaume du
maroc des algériens évidemment
mécontents considère la décision
américaine comme une ingérence dans un
problème interne
le maroc a toujours été considérée comme
une menace politique économique et
militaire
face à cette situation conflictuelle
entre les deux pays la france aurait
ainsi l'occasion de participer à la
construction d'un maghreb pacifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez la
livre libanaise sont tenues bas
historiques sur le marché noir
la devise du pays du cèdre a frôlé les
10 mille livres pour un dollar
les manifestants ont défilé hier soir
dans les rues de beyrouth pour exprimer
leur colère face à l'effondrement
économique et la gestion du gouvernement
un genre un sujet signé jordi demory
avec clémence pital c'est un nouveau cri
de détresse poussé par les habitants
face à l'aggravation de la situation
dans leur pays ce mardi soir ils étaient
des centaines à manifester dans
plusieurs villes du liban dont la
capitale beyrouth déjà touché par une
grave crise économique
le pays du cèdre a vu sa monnaie
nationale atteindre son plus bas
historique sur le marché noir
frolon des 10000 libre pour un dollar
ils dégringolade qui a provoqué la
colère de la rue
comment les gens avec des fans ne
doivent plus acheter du lait et des
couches pour leurs enfants
aujourd'hui si vous allez au supermarché
qui vous dépenser entre 200 et 2000 et
300 mille livres libanaises vous
n'achetez que quelques petites choses
notre situation se détériore chaque jour
le pouvoir d'achat est si bas vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer il n'y a pas
d'essence au liban pour faire un plan il
n'y a pas d'électricité pour chauffer
nos maisons notre peuple est au chômage
le prix du pain est exorbitant et nous
ne pouvons plus rester à la maison
le liban est engluée dans la pire crise
économique de son histoire aggravée par
une impasse politique et la pandémie de
covin 19 face à cette situation
dramatique
le président michel aoun a appelé les
libanais du monde entier à soutenir leur
pays la diaspora peut aider le liban en
y font dans des institutions et en
créant des opportunités d'emploi pour sa
jeunesse
cela permettrait de réduire l' envie
qu'on les jeunes d'émigrer en raison de
la situation actuelle
une nouvelle chute qui intervient au
moment où la banque centrale du liban a
commencé à passer au crible la situation
financière des établissements bancaires
du pays
ces derniers avaient jusqu'à dimanche
dernier pour augmenter leur capital de
20%
une des mesures réclamées par la banque
centrale pour doper leur solvabilité et
leur niveau de liquidité
la dépréciation de la livre libanaise a
déjà entraîné en 2020 une hausse
drastique des prix un habitant sur deux
vit désormais sous le seuil de pauvreté
et pour en parler nous sommes ce avec un
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude lauzon question pourquoi
le liban s'enfonce tribu inexorablement
dans une crise économique qu'on suit
maintenant depuis déjà plusieurs mois
bah parce qu'il n'a pas su adapter son
économie aux nouvelles réalités
la crise elle est structurelle le liban
importe quatre fois plus qu'ils
n'exportent il importe ses produits
notamment agro alimentaire pour se
nourrir près de 7% du pib ils sont
consacrés et en fait dans les années
fastes
tout ça a été plus ou moins masquée par
le fait que beaucoup de capitaux de la
région à l'est et volontiers sur cette
plateforme financière accueillante que
constituait le liban c'était le cas dans
les années 50 à 60 pour les capitaux qui
craignaient les nationalisations en
egypte en syrie en irak
ça a été le cas ensuite même pendant la
guerre du liban des capitaux des
capitaux des revenus du pétrole
dans le fond le zyban à cette époque est
devenu une sorte de coffre fort
pour les pétrodollars et puis ceci
fonctionner avec un système bancaire en
effet sous capitalisées puisque les flux
importants
arrivées d'étrangers y compris des
investissements étrangers
eh bien on n'avait pas besoin de mesures
prudentielles habituel pour les banques
et le capital des banques étaient
notoirement insuffisant tout ça à la
durée ne peut nous pouvait durer qu'un
temps et aujourd'hui est bien aidé en
pleine crise on voit bien que l'année
dernière
une partie de la dette du liban n'a pas
pu être remboursés c'était donc un
défaut de paiement
la banque centrale s'attaque aujourd'hui
à s'être capitaux de la gestion des
banques privées mais elle refuse
l'audit de la banque centrale elle même
que demandent par ailleurs le fmi est
effectivement le fmi ne peut pas aider
le liban tant qu'il n'a pas obtenues
tant qu'il n'est pas au clair sur le
système financier libanais et c'est ce
qu'il a expliqué au liban l'année
dernière déjà bien avant l'explosion
dans le port de beyrouth
donc cette rivale est antérieure à
l'explosion du port de beyrouth et
aujourd'hui elle atteint son maximum
avec un taux d'inflation de 4 100 % la
proportion de la population active d'un
tiers est environ au chômage et 50 % de
la population est en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
c'est donc une situation économique tout
à fait dramatique mais pour la redresser
et bien en effet il faut réformer le
système bancaire il faut réformer aussi
sans doute la banque centrale le
directeur de cette banque centrale est
directeur depuis un quart de siècle
c'est un financier avertit qui vient du
secteur privé mais un quart de siècle
c'est peut-être un peu long et est en
effet le liban a l'habitude de traiter
avec ces élites traditionnelles les
élites le président libanais michel aoun
estime que la diaspora peut aider le
liban alors véritablement ce qu'elle
peut jouer un rôle économique important
est le point si elle se sent elle le
voulait elle se mobilise et puisque la
diaspora est plus nombreuse que ne le
sont les habitants du liban même le
liban ces sept millions d'habitants et
la diaspora
c'est quelque chose qui est entre 7 et
14 millions d'habitants
ça dépend si on prend toutes les
générations ont seulement les
générations qui ont émigré le plus
récemment elles ont émigré beaucoup en
amérique latine
beaucoup aussi en amérique du nord en
afrique en europe en france et celle
immigrés sont évidemment très actif et
généralement ont très bien réussi dans
les affaires
par conséquent il pourrait aider leur
pays d'origine
bien sûr le liban étant ce qu'il est est
un pays où les communautés jouent un
rôle très important
il compte notamment les communautés
religieuses cette aide passerait sans
doute par les communautés religieuses et
plus certainement encore par les réseaux
familiaux des familles s'est tendue
puisque le liban l'économie du liban
repose en quelque sorte sur quelques sur
quelques grandes familles et le
président aoun fait un appel pour qu'ils
viennent à l'aide du pays
ils ne le feront que s'ils ont confiance
dans l'équipe qui dirige le liban or
actuellement ce n'est pas le cas et ce
n'est pas le cas pour la communauté
internationale ce ne sera pas le cas non
plus pour la diaspora alors le pays du
cèdre pas de gouvernement en c1 depuis
maintenant six mois pourquoi est ce si
difficile d'en former un
c'est probablement parce que les
contraintes politiques intérieures et et
les pressions qui viennent de
l'extérieur sont trop fortes et ne
permettent pas de constituer un
gouvernement
donc actuellement on a un gouvernement
qui expédie les affaires courantes qui
est celui qui était en place au mois
d'août
il ya eu plusieurs tentatives pour
former un gouvernement par des
technocrates dans une équipe dirigée par
l'ancien ambassadeur
à berlin une autre tentative par
monsieur hariri lui-même est revenu et
ses tentatives ont échoué
elles ont échoué pourquoi et bien
notamment parce que l'habitude a été
prise d'un partage des ministères et
notamment le hezbollah réclamant un
droit de regard voire une sorte de
propriété sur les ministères où
circulent l'argent est actuellement le
gouvernement qui expédie les affaires
courantes comporte deux ministres issus
du hezbollah plus de ministre issu du
parti amal qui est proche du hezbollah
est en effet ses ministres contrôle le
ministère des finances le ministère de
la santé et le ministère de l'industrie
ce qui montre bien la difficulté parce
que ce que demande la communauté
internationale est ce que voudrait aussi
sans doute la diaspora c'est que ce
partage du gâteau cesse et qu'on ait des
gouvernements efficace et puisse se
mettre les réformes qui s'en posent en
oeuvre de façon à ce que la communauté
internationale vienne en aide à ce pays
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
ali boumendjel a bien été tués par
l'armée française en 1957 emmanuel
macron nom de la france vient d'admettre
officiellement la torture et
l'assassinât du militant indépendantiste
algérien cette annonce pourrait être un
premier pas vers la reconnaissance des
crimes de l'état français lors de la
guerre d'algérie et un premier geste
favoris l'ont peut-être un apaisement
des relations entre paris et alger un
apaisement voulue par les chefs d'état
des deux pays les détails avec maxime
hébert ali boumédiène ne s'est pas
suicidé il a été torturé puis assassiné
l' annonce était attendue par la famille
d'ali boumédiène et tout un pays
emmanuel macron a reconnu au nom de la
france
les circonstances réelles de la mort de
l'avocat et militant durant la guerre
d'algérie
64 ans après les faits le 23 mars 1957
le partisan de l'indépendance de
l'algérie pacifistes et francophile est
enlevé torturé puis assassiné son
meurtre est maquillé en suicide par
l'armée française
le mystère autour de sa mort ce coup
notamment le monde intellectuel français
43 ans après les faits dans son
autobiographie le général paul
aussaresses reconnaît avoir donné
l'ordre de tuer le dirigeant algérien la
famille d'ali boumnijel entame alors son
combat pour la reconnaissance des faits
nous sommes en juillet 2020 et emmanuel
macron commandes à l'historien benjamin
stora un rapport sur les questions
mémorielles portant sur la colonisation
et la guerre d'algérie
paris veut se réconcilier avec alger et
reconnaître les crimes commis par la
france
sans excuses ni repentance précise le
président français janvier 2020 rapport
et préconisations sont publiés parmi
celles ci la reconnaissance du meurtre
d'ali beau métier elle mais le rapport
est mal reçue par certains en france et
surtout par l'algérie qui l attend des
excuses ce mardi le président magron a
reçu la famille d'ali boumédiène
l'elysée a ensuite publié un communiqué
reconnaissant la responsabilité de la
france
[Musique]
réactions diverses au sein de
l'opposition marine le pen présidente du
rassemblement national et dont le père a
été accusé d'avoir pratiqué la torture
durant la guerre d'algérie y voir un
aveu de faiblesse et une relecture de
l'histoire inacceptable
c'est en revanche un geste important que
ça lui alexis corbière député de la
france insoumise
nous ne privilégions pas de bonne
relation au détriment de l'histoire et
de la mémoire c'est la réponse du
président algérien abdel madjid tebboune
à son homologue emmanuel macron si les
deux hommes se sont engagés à oeuvrer à
la réconciliation des mémoires
al'approche du 60e anniversaire de son
indépendance l'algérie affirme vouloir
dialoguer mais refuse tout compromis sur
l'histoire de la colonisation et de la
guerre est le petit-fils d'annie et
boumendjel s'est dit ému de la décision
du chef de l'état français pour lui
cette annonce on n'effacera pas le crime
et ses conséquences sur sa famille mais
les importantes pour les générations
futures et le rétablissement de la
vérité écoutez ça va pas l'effacer
le crime unit ce qu'on a pu en vivre
est-ce que ça a pu l'être pour nous nos
parents étaient détruits par part ça la
recette cette histoire nous avons été
détruits par ça et cette histoire
le point n'est pas de sauver les
anciennes générations mais de protéger
les futurs et de leur expliquer ce qui a
été fait par le passé et ce qu'il ne
faut pas commettre
l'histoire s'est passée d'une manière la
question aujourd'hui n'est pas de l'art
faire parce qu'on n'a pas la possibilité
mais de faire en sorte que cette vérité
donc la vraie vérité rejoignent une
histoire et que chacun puisse se faire
son propre avis sur le sujet les yers et
c'est un grand pas pour notre famille
mais je pense aussi pour pour les
milliers qui qui ont vécu les mêmes
atrocités
emmanuel lacroix lui-même annoncé cette
reconnaissance aux petits-enfants donc
d'avis et mendjel cela fait partie des
gestes d'à peine dépaysement recommandé
par l'historien benjamin stora
recommandations effectuées dans son
rapport sur la colonisation et la guerre
d'algérie afin de permettre la
réconciliation des mémoires dans ce
conflit
alors question ce geste permettra-t-il
de relancer le dialogue mémorielle entre
la france et l'algérie emmanuel macron
doit-il poursuivre dans cette voie et
suivre les recommandations de ce rapport
sera c'est l'objet de notre face à face
ce soir
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler un mot à mourad
pardon à nous président de l'association
agir association des juristes formation
et réparation pour les harkis vous êtes
ancien maire de volvic vous êtes
également fils de harki vous avez
d'ailleurs écrit plusieurs livres sur ce
sujet dans cet ouvrage de référence et
ils sont devenus harkis aux éditions
fayard bonsoir mourad merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés vont remettre qu'à qui
vous êtes fondateur de l'association
mémorielle les oranges et on le rappelle
vous êtes co rédacteur en 2015 d'un
appel pour la reconnaissance des crimes
coloniaux par la france en algérie merci
à tous les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
on a entendu une réaction plutôt
positive du petit fils qui salue donc
une avancée vers la vérité et la
réconciliation mohamed kaki votre
réaction à ce geste aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron coûté c'est une bonne nouvelle
c'est un pas important dans un processus
est un processus à partir duquel le
rapport de benjamin stora d'une part
mais aussi les revendications des
associations comme les oranges sur ce
travail mémoriel important dans le but
de créer les conditions de la réussite
d'un ou d'une nouvelle relation entre la
france et l'algérie
donc moi je salue 7,7
cette nouvelle jeu parce que c'est
important en plus les conditions dans
lesquelles elle s'est faite c'est à dire
qu'il a reçu la famille et comme la
famille odin d'ailleurs il a été chez
eux et je trouve que ça c'est un acte
d'humanité important il faut le
reconnaître quand il ya des bonnes
choses il faut les reconnaître cependant
ce n'est pas suffisant
ce n'est pas suffisant parce que nous on
souhaite c'est que
la guerre d'algérie soit qualifié comme
crime contre l'humanité parce qu'il ya
eu des choses terribles et pas seulement
entre le 1er novembre 1954 et 1962 mais
depuis le début de la colonisation
depuis 1830 et notamment avec le
sinistre individu que vous connaissez
qui est le général bugeaud pour lequel
d'ailleurs nous avons fait avec olivier
le cour grandmaison et l'association les
oranges une pétition importante que nous
avons lancée pour le retrait des rues et
des plaques et surtout les statuts en
france de ce sinistre individu qui a été
l'ennemi de la république d'une part
puisqu'il a voulu réinstaurer la
monarchie et d'autre part qui a écrasé
aussi la commune
on va aller évidemment il a tué de très
nombreuses algérie recueillir la
réaction tout d'abord à ce geste de mots
rendent à vous comment vous qualifieriez
ce geste emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
moment des homo je crois que c'est ce
qui s'inscrit dans sa volonté de tenir
un discours de vérité sur cette période
qu'il faut revenir à la commande de ce
rapport stora la commande était clair
c'était dur car l état des lieux juste
et précis ce qui a pu être fait de ce
qui reste à faire est également de
travailler à l'apaisement à l'apaisement
et la sérénité ce sont les propres
termes de la lettre de commande à
l'égard de tout ce que ça a été à cette
histoire avec cette pierre a meurtri
donc il y avait à la fois vouloir
réconcilier si c'est le terme exact en
fait en tout cas d'améliorer les
relations entre la france et l'algérie
par un discours de vérité mais aussi de
réconcilier des populations françaises
qui ont été meurtris par cette guerre ce
soit les harkis qui soit les pieds noirs
les appeler et de ce point de vue ce que
je veux dire c'est que les vides a
manqué que saluer tous les gestes de
vérité historique
mais il faut pas que ce soit sanctionné
que c'est à dire que pour
ce temps si on veut la réconciliation il
faut que les deux le veuille et que les
deux faces il n'est pas dans le même
sens il faut aussi que l'algérie
or qu un regard lucide au regard
critique sur son histoire et qu'elle
reconnaisse elle aussi un certain nombre
de crimes commis durant cette guerre et
notamment les massacres de marquis et
notamment et les enlèvements et
disparitions de civils après
l'indépendance
oui on va mettre cac est votre réponse
il faut que les deux pays
on reconnaisse la responsabilité écoutez
la balle est d'abord dans le camp de la
france il faut quand même rappeler ce
qu'a fait la france et notamment
puisqu'on a parlé de ali boumendjel il y
a eu des centaines de milliers de ali
boumendjel qui ont été torturés qui ont
été assassinés froidement dans le cadre
d'une commande politique à l'époque et
donc ça aussi c'est important et
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que le président
macron lui même avait reconnu que
c'était un crime contre l'humanité qui
avait été fait contre le peuple algérien
et donc qui a créé tout un malheur dont
les harkis sont aussi d'une certaine
manière les victimes puisque c'est la
colonisation qui est un véritable poison
qui a créé et qui a disloqué le peuple
algérien dont en mille morceaux
et effectivement c'est là qu'il faut
revenir pour requalifier la chose en
crimes contre l'humanité et ça c'est
important nous reverrons d'ailleurs sur
la question du rapport de benjamin stora
que d'une part je salue mais qui en même
temps je nuancerais puisqu'il ya des
choses sur lesquelles nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur par exemple la
qualification d'un certain nombre de
mots quand il parle d' exactions quand
il parle de répression
alors qu'il s'agit de massacre de crime
d'état terrible où on affame et les
populations
vous savez chaque algérien a aujourd'hui
une mémoire meurtrie extrêmement
importante
alors évidemment il faudra aussi dans un
deuxième temps puisque là c'est le
regard d'un historien france 5
il faut aussi qu'ils aient les
historiens
j'ai rien face aussi ce travail puisse
le faire et dans des bonnes conditions
et évidemment ensuite il faut joindre
les deux bouts et voir comment mais il
n'y a pas de possibilité de se
réconcilier totalement sur deux souligné
que ce rapport à il met pas tout le
monde d'accord ils créent même la
polémique est minimale le débat je
propose de regarder cette lune nous les
céréales j'ai justement à cette tribune
morandais môme ou nounous fille et femme
d'heure qui est récusons le rapport
stora sur la guerre d'algérie
elle a été publiée cette tribune dans
les colonnes du figaro il ya un mois
regardez le rapport de stora sur les
questions mémorielles pourtant sur la
colonisation et la guerre d'algérie
obéit à des considérations politiques et
non historique au préjudice de la vérité
sur les harkis et fils de harkis une
réaction jésus coupe cela nous tel
surnom son père keith et à ce titre là
c'est intéressant d'avoir l'avis on
revient que c'est ce que vient de dire
on coulait vient c'est compliqué la
réconciliation parce que vous dites il
ya eu effectivement des milliers de
homogène
probablement mais il ya eu aussi des
dizaines de milliers de harkis qui
étaient des civils et leurs familles qui
ont été massacrés dans des positions
horrible après les accords d'evian
s'il était censé garantir la sécurité
des biens et des personnes
si on veut la vérité il la faut il est
la faute des deux côtés on peut pas sans
arrêt revenir sur les crimes
effectivement commis pendant la période
coloniale et ne pas vouloir voir ce qui
s'est passé après les accords d'evian le
dialogue n'était pas encore sèche que le
sang coulait déjà s'est désolé les fonds
ainsi que l'algérie importe le regard
lucide et critique sur son histoire
les algériens eux-mêmes aujourd'hui sans
doute combat vraiment envie qu'on arrête
avec cette histoire mystifiante mythifié
qui évidemment
pas la gloire du fln et qui cache non
c'est le mollet mais son père qui aimait
aussi les massacres de mai sa liste eh
ben ça vous déboulez ça mais certains
membres du dirigeant arrivé qu'on est
éliminé
il faut parler tout sens de la vérité
historique sur ce rapport un autre cas
qui on obéit
dans ce rapport à des considérations
plutôt politique et non historique
écoutez moi je crois qu'il faut pas être
naïf
on y lit à un contexte dans lequel ces
cris ce rapport d'une part il ya un
contexte dans lequel ce rapport est
remis
je vous rappelle qu'on est à un an des
élections nationales et qu'il ya des
enjeux extrêmement important un mais et
évidemment il y a des manques il y a des
choses importantes il ya aussi des
lobbys lobby de l'eau est ce vous voyez
monsieur le collègue parle aussi de d'un
certain nombre d'intérêts qui est celui
des harkis qui effectivement dont il
faudra parler bien sûr mais qui est dans
un contexte de conditions de production
historiques et que dont le peuple après
il appartient aux historiens algériens
aussi de dire leur mot il appartient
aussi au peuple algérien je pense qu'il
faut pas parler à la place des gens et
ça c'est sait quelque chose
alors évidemment on n'est pas naïfs
puisque aujourd'hui ce rapport notamment
sur la rhétorique sémantique 1 dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
exactions accès
il ya des tendances à minimiser le drame
terrible qui a vécu le peuple algérien
est ici un et ça c'est important
alors il ya eu des avancées comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure mais il
suffirait simplement que le président de
la république française puisse dire
clairement que c'est un un crime contre
l'humanité et que du coup on peut
repartir sur de bonnes bases
alors évidemment j'entends bien
que du côté qui a une critique à faire
aussi du côté algérien mais bien sûr
mais ça il faut que les uns et les
autres travaillent là dessus mais la
question des harkis
c'est une question importante mais elle
est aussi a été elle émerge donc dans
les conditions de l'histoire coloniale
c'est à dire que mes deux as un certain
qu'il faut le rappeler le mois de la fin
par an et la réponse ce que je veux dire
c'est que il faut une fois de plus j'ai
tenu à rappeler le contexte ce rapport
mais je crois qu'elle est l'objectif
objectif c'est de vouloir à la fois
améliorer la relation qu algérie en
faisant des gestes qui effectivement de
reconnaissance de vérité mais c'est
aussi reconsidérer les mémoires de
blessés deux des populations françaises
les à les appeler les arcs et des pieds
noirs et autres
çà et là de ce point de vue là il faut
aussi que le président de la république
pour suivre cette démarche c'est à dire
que reconnaître effectivement
l'assassinât de maurice audin coûte ali
boumendjel très bien mais il faut aussi
que la france reconnaisse pas certain
que la bourse qu'elle a abandonné les
arcs et parce que si effectivement en
algérie les a assassinés
c'est aussi parce que l'armée française
et les gouvernements des banques surtout
parce que c'est des gouvernants qui
déciderait pas l'armée a donné l'ordre
de ne pas rapatrier les harkis ou très
peu et donc il va bien falloir
reconnaître sa reconnaître cette
responsabilité ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
d'ailleurs allé président chirac sarkozy
et hollande en dix ans reconnaît la
responsabilité de l'état dans l'abandon
des harkis et donc ils font que
officiellement que ce soit reconnue
aujourd'hui un président de la
république par une loi
et qu'après effectivement l'algérie
fasse aussi son travail de
reconnaissance effectivement des
massacres qui ont eu lieu à ce moment là
on comprend que ce dont on a besoin que
dans les nouvelles générations besoin
c'est pas d'excusés c'est pas trop quand
ces deux vérités
c'est sur la vérité qu'on pourra bâtir
un avenir mieux ça sera demande la fin
merci
à tous les deux mondes amouzou battre
kaki d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
arte france pour ce débat merci à vous
deux c'est avec nous c'est la fin de
cette émission merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans quelques instants pour un
point complet sur l'actualité de la
journée
[Musique]
peu